Apryl blood is a new book from Laura
Martinez exploring the political feuds
in Florence during the Italian
Renaissance this history on book TV
feature is an hour thank you
ladies and gentlemen friends good
evening it's a its pleasure and an honor
really to be here shall I turn this on
I'm actually strapped for things is that
better
perhaps I should begin with a few words
about the contents of of April blood on
a Sunday in late April 14 78 at high
mass in the Cathedral of Florence a
circle of conspirators set out to
assassinate the two heads of the Medici
family Lorenzo the Magnificent and his
younger brother Giuliano the plot is
known as the Pazzi conspiracy still a
free republic at least in name Florence
for more than 40 years had been under
the devious rule of the Medici family
and their close supporters now on that
late April the Pazzi another family of
great Florentine bankers and the premier
rivals of the Medici were about to vent
their rage on a close relative by
marriage none other than the Magnificent
Lorenzo who had toiled for years Lorenzo
had toiled for years although working
behind their backs to keep the whole
Patsey clan out of office out of public
office and in Florence if you were rich
and distinguished and yet were secretly
denied the top political offices then
you lived without the public honors
which were yours by right of birth
and you were there by stripped of some
part of your humanity well the plot
miscarried the conspirators killed the
famous the glamorous Giuliano but
Lorenzo got away with a slight wound for
a few hours the Surat the survival of
the regime itself lay in the balance
then the tide suddenly turned against
the Pazzi and their accomplices and that
afternoon the backlash of reprisals
began a bloodbath followed men were
thrown out out of the windows of the
great government palace or they were cut
down at will and that evening according
to vaca Valley and the humanists politer
know the government square seems to have
been littered with body parts but the
event was far more than a local
Florentine affair for behind the Pazzi
Lumi looming up and lending them the
support of troops and money were Pope
Sixtus the 4th durante the King of
Naples and that great patron of the Arts
the Duke of Urbino papal troops had
approached the walls of Florence were a
city gate had been secured by the
conspirators and but for the play of
luck and the incompetence they would
have seized the palazzo della signoria
the government bastion among the
conspirators were at least a half-dozen
priests the Archbishop of Pisa and the
young Cardinal of San Giorgio one of the
Pope's nephews only the Cardinal who was
to be used as a bargaining stake would
escape with his life
all Italy was astonished and now Pope
king and Duke had to step forth from
behind the scenes that throw their
weight against Lorenzo and his friends
in Florence they proposed nothing less
than to reshape Florentine Foreign
Affairs war broke out the so-called
Patsy war and now to Milan and Venice as
Florentine allies stepped in to help
defend Florence and the Medici --an
regime there is no point in my telling
you more here when the book itself I
hope does a better job of laying out the
tale two points however called for a
note of emphasis first of all the Patsy
conspiracy plunged the Italian peninsula
into a major bout of tensions and
violence while also highlighting the
fragility of local alliances and the
fault lines of ambition envy and fear
secondly and this is most important
Florence
under the early Medici and right up to
the 16th century always nursed deep and
fierce resentments against the
domination of the Medici and of their
colluding circle of influential
Florentine supporters for they and their
regime were relentlessly tightening
their chokehold on the city's offices
and political councils suppressing open
debate destroying recalcitrant families
exiling opponents in short eroding the
Republican institutions that went back
in the history of Florence for more than
200 years and Lorenzo the Magnificent
love poet connoisseur author of spotty
carnival songs sometime neo-platonist
and patron of the Arts stood at the
pivotal point in the transition from
free Republic to tyranny a new
Renaissance principle the all but fatal
injuries inflicted on florentine
political sensibilities were revealed in
the mid 14 90s when with the overthrow
of the Medici the city's traditional
ruling class suddenly seemed set to tear
itself apart 60 years of Medici rule had
turned the old ideal of serving the
commune that is of serving the common
good into the mere question of whether
or not to fight for the return of the
Medici or to serve one of the several
aristocratic factions for sectarian
purposes the vision of a wider and more
impartial constituency had faded and
this explains the friar Savonarola
extraordinary authority during those
years because with his passionate plea
for the Republic and for a larger
political good he was filling a moral
vacuum at the heart of public life in
Florence
now in view of its extraordinary
lineaments the question arises why have
no serious historian ever cast a book
around the april plot the answer I think
has to do with our fear of seeming to
stoop down to what smacks of repulsive
violence and journalistic vulgarity
furthermore the plot has always struck
experts as so awful bloody and obviously
complete that it seemed to speak for
itself no historical research was
necessary it was a simple tale of one
powerful family going for the throat of
another and the other Italian states
came into the picture as mere lesser
participants in a dull game of
diplomatic chess but again the ugly
spectacle of Herald and quartered human
bodies was not for us the serious
historians even last week the academic
reviewer of April blood in The Times
Literary Supplement came up to me in
London and made a quick disparaging
remark about all those bodies I'm going
to tell you the story this evening of
how and why I wrote April blood when the
book climbed in to London's best seller
listings at the end of February about 15
days after publication
my publishers Jonathan Cape of the
Random House group were pleasantly
surprised and so was I why not the book
had been reviewed in the Sunday papers
and in some of the dailies with notices
that helped to launch it of all places
London's time out gave it a notice and
it was picked as the book of the week by
a publication called the week there were
then two rapid reprinting x' and
meanwhile the book had been selected by
the history guild in the UK and here in
America by the history book club who
made who made it their choice by
consulting the English original
something very odd was happening I had
published eight previous books but not
one not even remotely had ever attracted
such notice my playing field was another
where the vast majority of titles
academic books sell in the range of say
four hundred to eighteen hundred copies
and this only after two or three years
unless the book is regularly chosen for
classroom use having paid out a generous
advance for April blood Jonathan Cape
are supposed expected good continuing
sales but nothing like what they got so
what to conclude about buyers and
readers of the book that violence and
political terrorism mixed with a dash of
religious fervor Aryan that these are
the staff of a recent and powerful
appeal in the face of current anxieties
sure sure
I have no doubt that part of the books
commercial success has this element
behind it and most reviewers
interestingly closed in on that link
gave it some prominence and sought to
draw out a lesson or two but I also know
that I could have written April blood
with a different title and in such a way
as to attract no high-speed attention no
Press comments by directing the book at
a tiny group at the tiny group of
experts who work on the history of
Florence a mischievous spirit took over
I decided that I had done enough of that
written chiefly for the experts and this
is what I'd like to talk about because
it brings up the subject of academic
history in its ties with narrative and
styles of prose I left the university
ten years ago and once I got away
permanently away from colleagues and
students and a whole mode of thinking I
began to see something about the ways in
which history at the university is
hobbled by being aimed at a specialized
elite the story of how this happens and
how it rules our days is easily told it
begins in graduate school as we all know
and our preparation for the doctoral
dissertation at that critical time for
several years we live and run closely
with others like ourselves looking up to
the same ideals and perfecting a
language of specialists as we get ready
to jump the big hurtle that specimen of
erudition
the doctoral dissertation the summit of
our ambition is to win praise and glory
among the top scholars in the field for
the way to our first academic
appointment will be there and there too
is the source of the highest respect
that we can ever hope to have as
intellectuals Democrats in our hearts
yet in our work we look exclusively to a
select group in a stance that goes with
a whole style and language then if there
is a first book it is almost certainly a
revised version of the dissertation and
if a second book that it must be cut
more or less in the same fashion
particularly when we are to come up
against the anxieties of tenure further
promotion and research grants but there
is more but there is more above all the
web of intellectual relations in the
academic world more specifically in
one's history Department in hiring and
promotion committees in conversations
with colleagues and students and not
least it seems to me in a vital
correspondence with other specialists in
the field who are distant universities
or who may even reside in Europe all
this as we pursue our research and
writing leads us to produce a certain
kind of history actually I dare say the
most serious and reputable kind for if
there is such a thing as scientific or
objective history
historical writing that is that is
rigorous about evidence and analysis
then it can only come from the best of
academic history the foundations for
which are laid down in graduate school
and I would not change any of this
because if history is to be other than
propaganda for jingo Patriots and
low-grade politicians then it has to
strive for evidential rigor and detached
analysis I cannot emphasize this enough
and yet as we go on writing our academic
history something happens along the way
something almost destructive we can't
believe that there is only one audience
out there for us a single set of readers
the professor's especially the ones in
our field or if we produce a textbook
then we bring in that larger circle of
college and university students but
every serious textbook has its special
pleadings along with a particular tone
or flavor
it must smack of the classroom and this
of course can only be done by means of
language and style Simon Schama I would
venture Linda Colley and the late Roy
Porter and others like these must have
seen this in the course of their careers
that is that the most accomplished
professional historians go out of their
way to restrict their reading audiences
thereby abandoning their subject matter
- the popularizers and the so-called
professional writers with the result
that most people tend to get their
history in this mold if indeed they get
any at all now to indicate an
alternative route for the professional
historian I'm going to put all my cards
on the table this evening and reveal my
winding way to the writing of April
blood I wrote a novel a few years ago
and was lucky enough at a dinner party
in London to meet a literary agent from
New York we became friends she read and
liked the novel and agreed to help me
find a publisher in the first round of
activity we failed we failed the book it
seems was too highbrow in spite of the
fact that I had struggled to write
something popular if not quite a bodice
Ripper
over a period of a year or two I revised
it twice a good idea because I had
produced the first draft in 11 weeks in
something like an ecstatic surge of
energy meanwhile however time was
passing my friend an agent was eager to
have another book and she had excellent
contacts in publishing circles one of
whom it turned out was a leading editor
in London a man who liked my 1979 book
power and imagination one day she came
to me with a message from him he would
like very much to have a new book from
me a history all I had to do was to pick
a subject anything in the Renaissance
and submit a treatment or short sketch
which as I remember in this case came to
something like eight or nine pages if
the idea appealed to the editor one that
he could then press on his colleagues my
agent would negotiate the details and an
agreement would be drawn up with a view
to securing of course an advance on
royalties those of us who are retired
have to think about such things
well this is a standard feature you
should know of trade book publishing and
has behind it the wise assumption that
the more a publisher commits in advance
the more committed he is bound to be
thereafter in this regard at least
practice in trade book publishing is
radically different from anything to be
found in the procedures of most
University presses now suddenly I began
to think about the patsy conspiracy for
the very good reason that in one way or
another that dramatic April of 1478 had
been haunting me for more than 25 years
but my immediate private reaction at
that moment was one of shame what I
thought
write the history of an event that
smacks of sensationalism wasn't this why
no professional historian had ever
written a book on the famous plot could
I lend myself to it so that here was
that OD pro fanos attitude picked up
many years ago in the harvard graduate
school the amateur Herald Acton had
Britain had produced the only book ever
written on the subject and it is really
a scandal it is little more that what
Lorenzo de Medici is parish a Polly tano
had narrated in his mendacious
commentary on the conspiracy a complete
sort of whitewash of the Medici on the
one side and a total blackening on the
other side the Pazzi and their friends
and yet I couldn't as we say shake the
idea the more I thought about it the
more it appealed I had never written a
book in that vein it offered a challenge
I could go on writing the kind of
history that I'd been writing for years
and in the same style or I could break
away and try to put together a
compelling story well you can see I was
seduced
as for the horrendous bloodbath that
ended the foiled conspiracy
I would simply have to deal with that
and anyway why should I assume that
potential readers of the book might be
so squeamish as to be unable to put up
with descriptions of the horrid
desecration of human bodies are we in
the modern world so very far from doing
such things besides after 25 years of
occasional ramen nation I also had the
sense that something terribly important
had happened on that memorable April it
seemed to me that the electrifying
violence of the conspiracy and its
aftermath was the external show of
political hatreds and venomous
bitterness that cut deep into Florentine
society and ran back for more than 40
years and it also occurred to me but
only research could support this that
the April plot marked a historical
turning point I suspected that Lorenzo
de'medici survival and triumph verged so
to speak on finally breaking the back of
a republic which had been nourished by
open political debate for more than two
centuries but which now after 1478
witnessed the spread of a new tyrannical
climate a new guarding of speech the
oblique spread of fear and the growing
readiness of Florentine aristocrats to
throw in the towel
to put themselves under the rule of a
new senior a tyrant the threat of
sensationalism was now beside the point
I had the best reasons for turning my
hand to april blood but they remained
the question of how to write the book
how to organize it how to present it in
other words for whom would I be writing
for my peers in the profession as I had
always done or for my intelligent
friends in London who knew almost
nothing of what I do but whose interest
I might be able to capture with a new
account of the conspiracy this either/or
question I decided was false why not go
whole hog why not try to do the
difficult thing that is to write at one
and the same time for the two
constituencies employing a different
kind of prose a different tone and a
primary sense of narrative for if I
could narrate the explosive movements of
that April event and not lose their pace
then I was sure that any large circle of
readers would have the patience even the
interest to follow my stretches of
analysis and to take in all the
background material that would be
expected by the professional historians
the first task was to wean myself away
from some from some bad habits and to
force myself to use a more common or
classic language especially because the
writing of Florentine history is shot
through with words and turns of phrase
of the sort that professionals
constantly use as shorthand Ballia borsa
kept Amano trot de Monte screw Tino
gonfaloniere colleges in a very special
sense the bells etc I also decided that
it would be necessary at various points
to shy away from excessive detail such
as the particulars of papal policy in
central Italy unless I could lay my
hands on a strong enough source or text
that could be introduced to speak for
itself
if inserted in the right fashion the raw
testimony of the document such as a
letter a diary or say a sentence of
execution often appeals to lay readers
of history
but I could go on in this fashion citing
examples of the way in which I was
planning to write the book when the
following statement may express this
more effectively from the moment I began
to write April blood I kept telling
myself I am NOT writing for an audience
of specialists but rather for a much
larger educated readership paradoxically
however if I keep my passages of
historical analysis up to the most
serious and searching levels then the
specialists will also want to read the
book and perhaps even take it seriously
never mind that I am determined to use a
more everyday language just as my London
friends will accept all levels of
analysis if the story is well told
so the specialists in the field will
accept English prose of the kind often
found in lucid newspaper articles and as
for the question of style
yes it would be gratifying to achieve
some elegance but above all I told
myself look for clarity I should
emphasize here that at no point did my
publishers say anything at all about the
kind of book they desired I assumed of
course that they wanted a book that
would sell but remember university
presses also want books that sell and in
our day they want this very
much what I chose to do with the book
was entirely my own doing although I
wanted to reach the professors I confess
I was determined to do so by writing
first for a much wider reading audience
this is what made the game if you like
more interesting for me but I was not
yet done matters of language and tone
say nothing about narrative although
this was going to be crucial
how was I to handle a story already so
dramatic in its own right
I could easily blow it and tell the
thing poorly then which nothing would
have been more embarrassing so was it
best to cleave to the chronological flow
of events in the conventional manner of
historians or should I try a different
route since I couldn't make up my mind
about this I decided to work with a more
flexible overall form and I'll tell you
what once what I mean by that
fearing that my ability to describe
things would not be equal to the
narrative force of the conspiracy itself
I wrote each chapter in such a way that
it could almost standalone this required
here and there patches of repetition but
these could be easily deleted in the
finished manuscript and the advantage
was that I would then be
able to move the chapters around at will
here was my flexible overall form one
that would offer me the opportunity to
use flashbacks or elements of surprise
I felt I very much needed this resource
or fallback in case I failed to produce
the required verb for the explosive
scenes in the cathedral and in the
government palace in short yes I was
counting on narrative but never even for
a moment playing fast and loose with
accuracy or evidence for if I did
anything like that how would I ever
again be able to confront my cohort of
experts in the history of Florence and
therefore I don't mind telling you for
example that once the manuscript was
ready
two or three chapters were moved around
and now there was some consultation with
my editor at the Oxford University Press
in New York and the original first
chapter moreover was split in two the
second part becoming chapter 8 in the
end however in fact I used very few
flashbacks or other narrative Floyd's
reference to my friends in London is a
kind of refrain and there's a reason for
this
they are absolutely real and yet they
also serve as a metaphor because it was
by thinking about them
by conjuring up their faces that I came
to envisage a large ideal reading
audience in my experience of the
American scene
we tend in the USA to live in in ghettos
doctors and dentists see doctors and
dentists professors hunt with professors
showbiz people seek their own kind and
businessman likewise the result is for
historians certainly that the pivotal
experience of specialization in graduate
school the cultivation the long-term
cultivation of a technical vocabulary
and of a certain attitude continue and
are nourished for the rest of our lives
we speak the ordinary language of most
Americans to be sure but when it comes
to our work and especially to our
writing we pass over instinctively to a
language of mandarins and we address
only the coterie or core of experts in a
given field even lecturing to students
doesn't help much because we see at
least I did to elevate them I don't know
and perhaps rightly so by constantly
drawing them into our verbal Network
nevertheless we are not mathematicians
or physicists when they go out into the
social world they have to leave their
formula and arcane musings back in their
studies and places of work but we go out
into a world where people think then
about history and sometimes they do and
in any case they talk about it a great
deal mainly because of the impact of
current events on their daily
sensibilities if nothing else
politicians journalists and radio
pundits are often happy to talk to all
of us about the so called lessons of
history as if they were the experts and
what do we do we the professional
experts we say what do we do about
history in the forums where we might be
heard fast television and radio we do we
say nothing holding our noses we stand
above all media hype and so we surrender
talk about history to those who had best
abuse it and who had worst will want to
use it for their own sectarian or
murderous purposes I am suggesting that
when they have the writing facility to
do so professional historians have a
moral and social obligation to take
history out to a larger reading public
beyond college students and beyond the
university but how are they how are we
to do this if not through our books at
least in the first instance we assume
that lay readers are not for us cannot
be reached by us because they required
the honeyed pill of low narrative or of
something easily accessible such as a
dumbed down historical novel well
but isn't it a self-indulgent
convenience to assume that narrative has
to be low and honeyed it can be
demonstrated I would argue that there is
an enormous public of readers out there
who are able to take the best kind of
history from us but we have to break
away from our comfortable elitism and
write a more classic and common prose
while also seeking or even inventing the
narrative modes that can best convey our
different stories this means after the
doctoral dissertation or after the first
book or two that we must try to get away
from exclusive conversation with our
colleagues and talk as well to our
friends in London our friends in Boston
Chicago New York or wherever for us to
write for them too means a lot of work
it almost means retooling but it is the
only way ultimately to offer serious
historical reading to a public that
loves history that needs it and that is
somehow
rubbing up against it all the time yes
they may in turn simplify it I don't
know but our office somehow is to take
history to them not just to the
mandarins as best we can
I realize that certain historical events
and moments and some kinds of history
will have a wider appeal than others a
conspiracy of prices a triumph or sudden
change a great discovery all these for
example can be more easily and
compellingly narrated but it strikes me
that even the technicalities of legal
history to take a quite different
example could be unfolded or simplified
by tackling the subject through the
presentation of specific cases where the
flesh and blood so to speak of the
parties in conflict may be used to lead
out into the more abstract parts of
legal argument it often happens that a
history book appears to have some
special relevance for the present this
is partly luck but more I suspect a
matter of presentation especially if the
historian has written with some kind of
true engagement or commitment such as
when the subject touches something vital
in his or her experience it was only
after I completed the first draft of
April blood about five or six months
after the events of 9/11 that I began to
sense some distant residences in the
Pazzi conspiracy for the worst anxieties
of our day however there was no need for
me and certainly no honorable call to go
into the body of the text to go back
into the body of the text
with an eye to making adjustments of the
sort that would hint at possible links
with a present only once as I remember
in the prologue is there the passing
whisper of a connection between past and
present and then again in the concluding
pages with reference to the relentless
suppression of open political debate
under the Republican Medici and
particularly under the regime of Lorenzo
the Magnificent historians can no more I
think get away from politics than from
the air they breathe in this connection
politics if their personal commitments
are deep and informed then those
bearings will ghost through their way of
posing
historical questions and constructing
solutions but they the professional
historians do not pull past and present
together willfully intend any ously
instead this is a meeting that comes
about as part of a whole life experience
and so it comes as naturally as our
forms of reasoning thank you very much
just a reminder professor Martinez will
take questions but remember to wait for
both of the microphones to get to you
yes do please fake off so that I can
hear you
is there a good way to tell if you're in
a library and the history section which
books meet their standards of the
University and which are just is there a
way to tell when you look at books in
the library the history books which meet
the level of the university faculty and
which are just popular things that are
not to be trusted no I I can't think of
it certainly you can't judge a book by
it's cover EEMA but usually the covers
have all been removed them there so no I
can't think of a shortcut at all I think
possibly the quickest best way but you
can go wrong there too is to keep up
with with the reviews and in in the
reputable places not just in the
professional periodicals where it will
often take a review two or three years
to appear from the time a book is being
published I but I do think places like
the The Times Literary Supplement and
the New York Review of Books and and the
Sirius Sunday papers I would say the New
York Times Book Review and that that
kind of thing I think is extremely
important and when you've done enough of
that you begin to get a sense of what
things are and you can then more easily
more effectively make your choices
I don't know this is worth waiting for
thank you I didn't know if that was
worth waiting mine is worth waiting for
but I wondered what the reactions of
your former academic colleagues or
current academic colleagues are to this
message of yours to get out into the
world I know there were there were two
and three I said I would say that our
pen to it about three of the reviews in
London thus far were written by
academics one man at at Cambridge and a
woman in one of the London universities
yes they were there was no problem about
it they and I think they took the book
seriously yeah but I frankly have no
idea of what is likely to happen in the
field here and and and they need today
for instance the two major places for a
reaction to to the book a serious
reaction to the book do you intend to
devote any articles to this subject or
talk about it in truly academic fora you
mean the they gave the scene yes I think
it might be a good idea if I try to do
this this this little talk up in proper
form and try to place it somewhere
because I do feel passionately about it
I think that if I went back to the UCLA
now and I which I would like to do in
some way I would like to get all my
colleagues into a corner and talk to her
and talk to the graduate students and
tell them yes do this for the first book
or two but at some point you have to
begin to think of breaking away and
while doing a very kind of serious
history at the same time thinking of our
friends out there
all right you mention you made a
comparison between an agent whom you
made a comparison between your ear field
and what happens to scientists right and
I belong to and there was the same
attitude many many decades ago of being
very isolated and talking to one's
community but over the years something
has developed and that is the scientists
have become aware that it's very
important over the years over the years
the scientific community has realized
that it's very important to talk to
people that are not scientists yeah and
there is although initially we were
suspicious of scientists that became
popular rise above the field and that
has become accepted and there is a real
strong tendency at the moment to bring
out the field of astronomy in which I am
more physics to the public and often to
write two types of books not just the
book that you're trying to write which
covers both the professional area even
appeals to others but maybe two books
one that appeals to the through
professional community and others that
are slightly different but cover the
same topic which can refer to the other
one but I find commonality and what
you'll be talking about and write the
field I understood what you said I think
your point is a very good one for
instance in London I have a month of my
friends there are two scientists one of
them in fact was the man named John
Maddox is the editor of nature and these
guys they're they're extremely interest
in getting out and talking to their
friends a wide public and and when when
a scientist produces a court appearance
whether it is serious or not whether it
is dumbed down or not and they will they
will applaud the book that is well done
and respectively done and simply
dismissed the others and in fact I think
that much more of this kind of reaching
out is
d taking place in the field of science
for obvious reasons
then in ours where we think that we're
so close and yet we're very far in some
ways
okay
I find your discussion of mass for as a
specialized audience is very interesting
I'm curious to know what your opinion of
fictionalized accounts of history are
and I'm thinking of some books in
particular in the Italian field and that
you have about the echoes name of the
rose for example from the 80s I'm
thinking much more recently of a couple
books there seems to be a flourish of
fictionalized books that have to do with
Dante there's a recent book by Matthew
pearl called the Dante Club which is a
murder mystery that takes place in 19th
century Boston but it's steeped in
history medieval and sort of more recent
history there's another book by nikto
Shea's called in the hand of dante which
is steep very much in history in the
history of philosophy but it's also
hugely fictionalized in fantasy
wondering what you think the role of
those sorts of things are in bringing
history to the masses as well look again
if I heard you rightly it's it's it's
interesting and curious that the
historical novel is in I think it's
probably in here it's in in England I
know in another continent there must be
something about the contemporary world
that drives people towards the past
thing where they have a more more worked
out some more clearly defined world and
I see nothing wrong with that but I've
read enough historical novels to say III
would generalize this way and say that
there are some which are superb and some
that are dreadful it very much depends
on the historian on the kind of research
they done on how much there's one that
just been published in this field is
coming out here next year is called the
the birth the The Birth of Venus and
it's it's by Sarah Dunn Aunt Sarah Dunn
aunt
and it's it's about a young woman who
reads and speaks Latin in the 1490s and
falls in love with with a young painter
and there's some marvellous things in
that novel and some other things that I
would pour with one can pick up bits and
pieces of history and historical novels
but unless you actually know the the
that particular period there's no way of
knowing what you should pick up and what
you should not pick up well then thanks
to you all please join us for a glass of
wine and professor Martinez will take a
seat at the table over here I think
we'll get him a glass of wine too and he
would be happy to sign the books of
those of you who have them
Laura Martinez is a reviewer for The
Times Literary Supplement April blood
Florence and the plot against the Medici
is published by Oxford University Press
on the web at oh you P - usa.org next
week on history on book TV
Martha Ackerman's account of the 13
America